now are you retired
um
no i
you know i did i i tried that i'm
terrible with that i was about to say i
found one thing you announced it yeah
you announced it yeah you said i'm
retired yeah yeah you made the world say
oh [ __ ] damn farewell i just needed a
break okay but i really thought that you
know i was really burnt out at that time
i i i was releasing an album every year
96 97 98
and then in between that soundtracks
other people's albums uh
no
rockefeller tauren yeah like back to
back and you know i just looked up one
day and i was like
i'm tired i had never been on a vacation
to like
i want to say
2000 like my whole life and
you know i was just really burnt out at
that moment
how long how long do you think the break
was that you took
not long i just needed a uh
maybe a year maybe two years wasn't that
long it was like maybe three years
because i remember i went to death jam
it was three years ago you took off and
then you appeared it was like you
appeared on the track yeah and people
were like well what the [ __ ] i thought
he was yeah yeah
yeah and then it came back like 2007 i
believe
so maybe so three years so three years
and um
um
yeah i i don't know what what happens
next you know i'm
i'm not actively making music or making
an album or have plans to make an album
but i never want to say i'm retired i
just you know it's a gift and who am i
to shut it off you know what i mean like
it's just like
it's open to
whatever and it may have a different it
may
you know a different form a different
interpretation maybe maybe it's not an
hour maybe it is i have no idea
but i just you know just going to leave
it open
[Music]
you